et
reconnu territoire de talent
saint-quentin-en-yvelines continue
d'encourager les savoir-faire avec des
structures adaptées aux ambitions de la
nouvelle génération
ce mois ci nous rencontrons donc des
jeunes talents du territoire et nous
débutons à magny les hameaux avec paul
21 ans un jeune designer créateur avec
ses amis de toxic instruments une
guitare unique est particulièrement
innovante
une guitare qui est connecté sans fil
visuellement j'ai séparé les zones de
prise en main et les zones techniques en
fait vu que c'est parti là elles sont
dix sont séparés et visuellement on va
pouvoir les enlever et changer la forme
les couleurs les matières pour vraiment
adapté instruments à notre personnalité
notre vision d'un instrument un
instrument que toxiques que des
particulièrement bien puisqu'une partie
de l'équipe est à l'origine du festival
food rock qui a lieu chaque année à
magny les hameaux pouvoir avoir une
liberté de mouvement accrue c'est en ça
qui me semblait important également
c'était de pouvoir bouger
moi je sais quand je joue de la guitare
je suis dans ma chambre je ne supporte
pas avoir un fil à la patte quoi on a
fait un test avec un guitariste d'un
groupe assez connue qui a testé notre
guitare on était à dix mètres de l'ampli
et ça marchait plutôt bien
on s'est dit notre sangles elle a besoin
adaptable et on va pouvoir la règle et
vous avez vu c'est vraiment juste avec
un seul doigt ces bancs adaptable et ça
se fait très rapidement
aujourd'hui paul et ses complices sont
prêts à lancer une pré série
d'instruments plus ils ont fait un appel
de fond sur la plateforme kiss kiss bang
bang et ils ont encore plein d'idées en
tête
notre but ultime effectivement si le
connecter à internet et pouvoir
faciliter transit des informations entre
aude rugby entre entre guitariste
espérons que ça roule pour eux aussi
bien que pour alan brachet nini montrent
un de 17 ans véritable prodige du
triathlon formé au triathlon club de
saint quentin en yvelines fréquente
assidûment le gymnase des pyramides à
voisins le bretonneux et la piscine de
guyancourt au championnat de france
le traitement j'ai fait 2e ou une très
bonne place il ya deux ans j'ai tout
gagné j'ai gagné le championnat de
france 2 sera construite duathlon et
d'aquathlon j'ai gagné je peux du monde
scolaire s'il ya deux ans donc un
portrait qu un palmarès exceptionnel qui
nécessite un entraînement régulier et
des sacrifices
j'ai commencé très tôt à l'âge de 6 ans
c'est mon père qui en avait déjà
du coup je les suis dans ce sport où
beaucoup de détermination déjà ça c'est
évident est vraiment une grande montée
bah ça peut aller de 16h à je peux aller
même si à 25 heures en stage et en
semaine en grosse semaine à une les
courses ça peut aller avant de le vert
d'entraînement
il enchaîne beaucoup les cours et
l'entraînement après j'ai beaucoup de
temps libre
maskemane et j'aimerais bien aller aux
championnats d'europe juniors et elles
aussi elles en connaissent un rayon pour
ne pas vous laisser partir en roue libre
elle s'appelle l'or et lila elles ont
respectivement 26 et 27 ans elle son
psychologue
elles ont monté à guyancourt avec l'aide
de la maison de l'entreprise de saint
quentin en yvelines
le cabinet discover pour réinventer
l'apprentissage
on a beaucoup beaucoup de petits
patients qui viennent nous voir en
disant que l'école ça les ennuie n'ont
pas envie d'y aller
le monde a beaucoup changé et
est très stimulant en dehors de l'école
comment l'adapter aux enfants
d'aujourd'hui
comment faire pour que ce soit un
apprentissage autre fait plus efficace
peut-être plus motivant les méthodes qui
seraient adaptés à chacun et en
particulier aux enfants qui sont en
grosse difficulté scolaire
tout ce qui est dit ce dyslexiques les
dyscalculiques les hyperactifs
le principe c'est que l'on fait des
bilans pour déterminer exactement le
profil de l'enfant alors ça va être est
ce qu'il est plutôt positif et ce qu'il
est plutôt visuel
quels sont les points d'entrée en fait
pour que l'apprentissage soit efficace
ensuite 2
lui apprendre à se connaître et l'idée
c'est que la fin ils soient indépendants
qui sache exactement ce qu'il faut faire
comment apprendre utiliser les bonnes
techniques
c'est vraiment très efficace surtout
pour pour ramener aussi la confiance en
soi des enfants des méthodes qui ont
fait leurs preuves et qu'elle se propose
de partager à la faveur de formation à
destination des parents des enseignants
et des éducateurs qui souhaiteraient
aider les enfants en difficulté scolaire
direction maintenant la fac de médecine
de l'université de versailles saint
quentin en yvelines
nous y retrouvons georges ghorayeb
investi noix de 20 ans étudiant en
deuxième année membre de l'association
poèmes il s'est investi dans le projet
de solidarité internationale
samba un acronyme qui signifie six
amoureux de la médecine bâtisse l'avenir
et donc on va au brésil dans la plus
ancienne favelas de sao paulo pour faire
pour rénover les salles de classe les
agrandir ses salles de classe d'une
d'une association franco brésilienne qui
est déjà là bas qui s'appelle arkados
abers cette association oeuvre pour
l'art et à sa réinsertion et pour la
formation de jeunes issus de quartiers
défavorisés justement et donc on va
là-bas pour apporter les fonds
nécessaires pour acheter le matériel
nécessaire à cette réflexion peut en
même temps va faire de l'animation pour
ses enfants
j'ai trouvé intéressant de m'investir
dans
d'un projet de solidarité internationale
c'est la première fois que je le fais
est donc allé voir les populations leur
apporter un peu de soutien à morales un
peu de bonheur il faut trouver le temps
de s'engager il faut récolter les fonds
nécessaires donc il faut récolter 5000
euros ce qui est beaucoup donc il faut
vraiment trouver le temps de fer des
stands comme on fait à la fac en ce
moment trouver des places au niveau par
exemple du marché pour pouvoir vendre et
promouvoir notre projet ils vont avoir
un sens humain enfin faut bien sûr aimer
aider les gens elle proche de mes a
priori quand on fait des études de
médecine c'est quelque chose qui doit
être acquitté sachez qu'ils payent leurs
billets d'avion et leurs vaccins sur
leurs propres deniers par ailleurs si
vous souhaitez les aider à financer leur
projet rendez vous sur le site de
l'association poèmes direction
maintenant la verrière où nous
retrouvons calysto foule 24 ans qui est
à la fois producteur manager et
directeur artistique à la tête de crise
production structure sur laquelle il
travaille depuis qu'il a l'âge de 16 ans
soutenu par des partenaires privilégiés
tels que le scarabée ou l'espace
culturel aimé césaire dénicher des
talents essayer de travailler avec
l'artiste en fait à trouver une couleur
artistique en fait à son projet à ses
chansons parfois peut-être touché aussi
un peu des textes avec lui et la musique
et ensuite dans fait une fois toute la
partie musicale et sur pied et fait donc
l'enregistrement et à nous de travailler
pour pour essayer de le faire connaître
et ça passe aussi par la scène du
festival des premières parties et puis
au fur et à mesure à prêtera aussi sur
un album et fait ressortir ce projet là
c'est appeler relancer envoyer des mails
le faire la prog essayer d'être au
courant de tous les nouveaux festivals
de toutes les salles en fait qui s'ouvre
et qui sont ouvertes à la programmation
donc c'est à nous d'aller vers ces
programmateurs l'aï laissé leur proposer
notre artiste et de le revendre leurs
artistes en fête et kaliste s'occupe
également de la communication des
plaquettes des flyers et gère les clips
et les photos en lien avec des
professionnels qui l'accompagnent depuis
longtemps il est en ce moment occupé
avec deux artistes en qui il croit dur
comme fer
ambre qui est une artiste
pop urbaine sol et délicat qui est plus
hip hop chanson et musique urbaine et
ambra 20 ans et elle aussi elle guérit
rembrandt fait donc on l a fait déjà les
premières parties du nabot déjà et
délicat donc là on est en plein travail
on sort un premier morceau pour un mois
d'avril avec un premier clip qui va
suivre très prochainement et il y aura
un concert donc pour la saison prochaine
qui normalement aura lieu au scarabée
salah derrière mais on peut dire que
luis il connaissait musique mais dans la
création audiovisuelle il s'appelle
hélène et romain ils ont 22 et 24 ans
ils ont été formés à l'institut
international de l'image et du son à
elle en cours c'est là qu'ils se sont
rencontrés et c'est là qu'ils ont eu
l'idée de créer la websérie vous allez
tomber malade soit trop bête parce qu'on
peut tomber malade maintenant tu as dis
donc je suggère rappel pour quand on est
descendu déjà sur le web on peut faire
ce qu'on veut comme on veut quand on
veut où il suffit à près de s'en donner
les moyens
et après d'assumer ses ambitions mais
wen le web nous offre une liberté on
n'en a pas besoin de passer par des
producteurs
on peut écrire créer et diffuser nous a
d'abord choisi de fermer réapprendre à
chercher un thème et on s'est un peu
inspiré de ce qu'on est tous les deux
nos références c'est plutôt cette espèce
d'humour absurde de personnages décalés
sorti leur univers ni leur zone de
confort mais partie sur les taux grecs
des fans de mythologie les deux on
écrire ensemble trop gagner des épisodes
ensemble qu'on a déjà marque dès la
saison 1 qui a écrit à quand sadate
aussi à nos amis comédiens - technique
outre la météo etc
il ya beaucoup de comédiens est pas
moins des techniciens maintenant et une
fois que ça c'est fait il faut ensuite
trop le temps de faire du montage du
mixage composé la musique
j'ai fait la fête samedi c'est le
critère c'est nasser ça sert à quoi un
projet ambitieux que la salle
saint-quentinoise le prisme mettra en
avant à l'occasion d'une projection
spéciale 18 avril à partir de 17h30
et après cette projection on tournera en
direct devant le public
une scène qui sera intégré au prochain
épisode
nous terminons notre série de portraits
avec fabio da silva trappistes de 24 ans
à la scolarité brillante et qui est
entré en 2006 à la fac de médecine de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines
là il réussit sa première année avec
brio du 1er mai en fait on suit ensuite
un circuit qui a été assez simple facile
parce particulièrement la vie a
notamment la femme de 50 ans ou
on choisit nos stages et en fait on va
tout droit jusqu'à la sixième année et
là on a un concours cette fois nationale
où on était huit mille 8000 et ensuite
en fonction de son classement on choisit
sa spécialité et son lieu d'internât
donc j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir rester
sur paris qui était mon choix et de
choisir la spécialité de cancérologie
médical qui était une spécialité qui me
tenait à coeur
là je suis en l'hôpital saint-antoine
donc un hôpital dans plusieurs
arrondissements de paris je suis je suis
un stage d'hématologie l'hématologie ces
maladies du sang il faut savoir
s'imposer je pense que stricto sensu on
dirige personnes travaille avec des gens
ont travaillé que des équipes
paramédicales des infirmiers et
kinésithérapeutes des aides soignants en
termes de hiérarchie on est au dessus de
personnes mais c'est vrai qu'on a des
directives des consignes à donner parce
qu'au final
responsable de la prescription c'est
nous on sait qu'on a des liens entre les
mains on sait qu'on n'est pas seuls
qu'on n'est pas on n'est pas isolés
qu'on n'ait pas laissé à l'abandon que
les situations difficiles on a on a
toujours l'hôtel le chef le senior qu'on
peut qu'on peut appeler on sait qu'un
patient ça se gère avec avec les
médecins avec les paramédicaux et
et c'est vrai qu'il faut une certaine
maturité aujourd'hui sa bio est heureux
du chemin accompli
si on si on en est là c'est parce qu'on
a des parents qui l'aiment venant d'un
milieu ouvrier
mais on peut voir leurs enfants on va
réussir des études ma chance que c'est
pour les remercier les récompenses et de
tout ce qu'ils ont fait pour nous et de
leurs efforts qui donc répondre